what if everything you thought you knew
about weight loss was a
[Music]
lie hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome
to aby's kitchen for decades we have
known that weight loss comes down to a
simple equation of calories in minus
calories out that everyone just needs to
follow the simple laws of thermodynamics
to have an equal chance of losing weight
well what if I was going to challenge
that assumption what if 100 calories of
chocolate had a different effect on the
energy equation than 100 calories of
broccoli what if the calories in an
apple to me were different than the
calories in an apple to you the math
here just ain't going to math what So
today we're going to be doing a deep
dive into the health of our gut and
answer the age-old question is a calorie
a calorie a calorie and a quick thank
you to Aaron Davis my Rd colleague for
supporting me on this don't forget to
hit up my general disclaimer including a
reminder that this video is not an
encouragement or a suggestion to try to
lose weight or to manipulate calories I
am simply going to be answering a super
interesting sciency question that is
consistently misunderstood in the weight
loss Community also don't forget to hit
up my description for my free Hunger
crushing combo ebook for some healthy
meal and snack ideas let me hop in here
quick to tell you about today's sponsor
zbiotics I love all my sponsors but
rarely am I so excited that I would like
leap at the chance to buy shares in this
company that's how much I love it but if
you haven't heard me talk about this yet
zbiotics is a probiotic drink that you
take before you drink alcohol to prevent
the rough morning aftermath this is the
world's first genetically engineered
probiotic invented by a team of PhD
microbiologists that's been specifically
designed with this one job in mind
basically when you drink alcohol gets
converted into a toxic byproduct AED
alahh that's responsible for the rough
next day zbiotics produces an enzyme
that breaks down that byproduct in your
gut this is no word of an exaggeration
but I have turned my entire friend
Circle onto these things by giving them
out before dinner my friends are now
telling their friends about them because
we just cannot rally with our kids
without it now this is not an invitation
to over andbe you still need to drink
responsibly stay hydrated and of course
get a good night's rest but this
absolutely helps me function the next
day with my kids so this Halloween you
can pair your candy and Cocktails with
zbiotics to avoid a spooky next morning
if you know what I mean go to zbiotics
docomo Abby sharp at checkout you can
also sign up for a subscription using my
code so you can stay prepared no matter
the time or occasion zbiotics is backed
by 100% money back guarantee so if
you're not satisfied for any reason they
will refund your money no questions
asked and don't forget to head to
zbiotics
docomo for 15% off thank you again to
zbiotics for sponsoring this video okay
so as I discussed in my video right here
weight loss efforts are
made a little bit complicated by a wide
range of compensatory mechanisms that
our body throws into high gear to
maintain our homeostatic set point
weight I also went to detail into why
calorie counting isn't a precise science
in a very controversial video that got
people really riled up right here but as
a little recap there are several factors
that influence our body's calorie needs
Beyond those that just go into formulas
or calculators that we have access to
online so things like muscle Mass
climate hormonal status weight history
ethnicity and a lot more there's also
the thermic effect of food and changes
to the calorie count with chewing and
cooking not to mention the whole calorie
calculation is based on a ridiculously
small study and the research was
thoroughly flawed but further
complicating this already very
complicated flawed science is the role
of our gut and that is what we're going
to focus in on today so we have ample
research at this point that links
specific gut microbiome profiles or
characteristics to obesity and metabolic
syndrome in other words fat people's
guts just look different than thin
people's guts we tend to see specific
bacterial species in the guts of folks
who are overweight and other species
that are found in folks who are lean
with the most prominent observation
being that obese folks tend to have high
firm acutes to bacteria deaths ratio so
this High f2b ratio is one example of
gut dysbiosis neither of these bacterias
are necessarily bad but disrupting the
ratio is where we see some trouble but
the question is what comes first the bad
microbiome or the diet related obesity
in other words is our diet to blame for
ruining our gut microbiome which then
becomes a marker of obesity or does our
gut microbiome inherently Destin us to
obesity let me go wash my hands and I
will answer that question for you
several bad T later well honestly we
don't totally know but it's probably a
little bit of both so we know that
genetics can alter our gut microbiome
and we also know that Mom's gut
microbiome can influence baby's
microbiome in utero as can breast milk
in that first year of life but if your
mom had a bad microbiome or a bad diet
it doesn't necessarily mean that you're
destined to be overweight how we nurture
our own microbiome through diet is
really key here what we eat has a direct
and important impact on which bacteria
species can grow and flourish and fiber
a prebiotics is the fuel that feeds the
good bacteria which is one of many
reasons why fiber is an integral part of
my Hunger crushing combo interestingly
in contrast one review of the literature
found that peoples whose diets was low
in fiber and high in animal protein had
guts with a ratio of high bacteroids to
low level of firmicutes which is
associated with IBD so no the carnivore
diet is probably not good for your
[Music]
gut now another diet that might not be
so good for the gut depending on how you
interpret it is something like If It
Fits your Macros now obviously this
could be done in a super balanced gut
friendly way but do you guys remember
when like fit Bros on Tik Tok and
Instagram we're promoting eating like
poptarts and like little Debbies for
weight loss I mean this might work just
fine for some folks to some extent for a
certain period of time but it's
certainly not best practice for weight
loss and we used to think this was just
because eating a food like Pop-Tarts
which is low in hunger crushing
compounds simply makes staying in a
calorie deficit a little bit more
difficult because you're going to get
hungry but new research suggests that we
may actually absorb more calories from
those Pop-Tarts versus the equivalent
number of calories of apples or peas let
me explain so a recent 2023 study
proposed that a calorie is not just a
calorie it's not just about how many
calories are available to us it's about
how many of those calories that our body
uniquely can use and absorb and that
depends on our gut so Ultra processed
foods like Pop-Tarts are quickly
absorbed in the upper gastrointestinal
tract which means we can kind of like
squeeze more energy out of them but
higher fiber foods make their way into
the large intestine where bacteria kind
of like await their feast the bacteria
can digest and absorb some of those
available calories leaving fewer excess
calories to be potentially stored as fat
so our body and our microbes are
basically fighting over this energy
right
[Music]
and the more processed the food the more
likely we are to win and the less likely
we are to share with our microbes rude
right as my Justice obsessed 5-year-old
would say sharing means caring but
anyways in this study they gave one
group a very fiber rich diet lots of
resistant starch fruits veggies beans
whole grains that was designed to make
the microbes super happy happy and then
they gave the other group a diet that
was rich in Ultra processed foods so
things like a lot of white bread ground
beef American cheese cheese puffs
cookies deli meats Etc now this was a
small study but super super rigorous in
design because the partipants had to
live in a metabolic Ward where every
single calorie was accounted for that's
really hard to do and it wasn't just the
inputs that they were controlling they
were collecting the outputs too AKA they
were collecting everybody's poop and
when they looked at said poop they were
able to measure the Lost calories we'll
call them the lost boys so the fiber
group lost on average
2117 calories per day while the
processed food group only lost about
half of that and some people lost around
400 calories in the fiber rich Group
which alone could create a calorie
deficit resulting in almost a pound loss
per week so this likely came down to the
existing health and diversity of each
participants microbiome the more good
bacteria and the more diverse the party
going on down there the more calories
they can Goble up and if you're thinking
well wouldn't losing calories just like
make you more hungry and want to eat
more actually no the study found that
the fiber group did not experience any
increase in hunger despite losing the
fight for more of those calories and
that's not even the most interesting
part I know I'm geeking out here but
stay with me not only did the fiber
group group not absorb or utilize as
many calories but feeding the gut
bacteria also produced short chain fatty
acids and increased levels of glp1 and
if that term sounds familiar it's
because people are spending up to $1,000
per month to inject themselves with this
to help suppress their appetite and help
them lose weight AKA OIC so this is like
part of the package deal when you eat
more fiber it's truly magical stuff and
obviously as I said this is a a small
study and we need a lot more research to
confirm these findings on a much bigger
scale but it may offer some really
interesting insights into what we know
about a predominantly Whole Food
plant-based high-fiber diet and weight
management so for example research has
Associated a reduction in short chain
fatty acids which we just mentioned with
a higher risk of obesity so short chain
fatty acids are basically the byproduct
of bacteria fermenting resistant
starches and fibers that act as
signaling molecules to reduce appetite
hormones like py and grin and increase
metabolism and calorie expenditure and
research is now exploring how fiber
supplementation can increase these short
chain fatty acids in the gut on a dose
dependent basis to have all of these
potential weight management effects
disbiosis is linked with obesity and we
know that our diet can play a role in
feeding the good bacteria to help to
correct this disbiosis while also
feeding our bacteria instead of our fat
cells more calories if that makes sense
and all of this plays into weight
management so if you're like okay Abby
just tell me what to do here this next
section is for you so obviously it
starts with diet that's what we're here
prebiotics and probiotics so prebiotics
are the bacteria food which as we've
established is predominantly fiber so
dietary fiber consensus recommends about
14 G per 1, calories per day which is
anywhere in the neighborhood of like 25
to 38 G of fiber but just like you might
like broccoli and I might like brussels
sprouts different bacterial strains can
kind of be like picky about their
preferred fuel so if we want a diverse
and plentiful microbiome we need
different fiber sources every fiber
promotes its own unique microbiotic
action so bacteroids like soluble fiber
oats barley apples Etc and like actino
bacteria like insoluble fiber so things
like wheat bran or nuts Etc now I think
I've paded this enough let me wash my
hands and I'll tell you more a few
minutes later now probiotics are sources
of the bacteria themselves AKA fermented
foods like sauerkraut kombucha kimchi
kefir yogurt Etc we also know that
probiotic supplements can help to
restore that optimal firmicutes to
bacterio at ratio so the most common
study for this are the lactobacillus and
the basilla strains and sacchromyces
yeasts and while fiber can absolutely
help you better manage your appetite and
hunger we do still want to be mindful
about overc consumption so one study
found that increase in calories from
2400 to 3400 increased the firmicutes by
20% and decreased the bacterio debts by
another 20% Which is the same ratio
associated with risk of obesity now
exercise can also modulate that bacteria
by effectively promoting bacterial
diversity improving that firmicutes to
bacterio dats ratio increasing the
proliferation of bacterial species that
can improve gut barrier functions and
stimulating bacterial species that
produce those short chain fatty acids
and remember those short- chain fatty
acids help to suppress hunger and
improve our metabolism so this is a very
complicated subject but I think that the
solution is actually quite simple add
more high fiber Whole Foods to your diet
it's also a good reminder as to why my
Hunger crushing combo works over
something extreme or restrictive like
keto or carnivore and it encourages
variety which as we've established is
really key to keeping our very diverse
microbiome happy and it also encourages
to add fiber which not only contributes
to Sati because of its ability to slow
down digestion and flatten the blood
sugar curve but it also increases those
short chain fatty acids production which
helps to manage appetite if you're
interested in other gut health videos
leave me a comment below because I could
geek out on this all day I'm going to
throw my baked French toast in the oven
right now and on that note that's all
that I have for you guys today thank you
again to Aaron Davis for research
support on this one it was a Dey I will
see you next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye